we're so happy to be here I'm Kim Gough
Cruz and I'm it's my privilege to
welcome you on this really beautiful day
as we honor our veterans throughout its
history Yale has been home to men and
women who have dedicated their lives to
the service of their countries we joined
together today to pay them tribute and
to reflect on the freedoms and
privileges that their sacrifices have
made possible we are honored to have
among us students faculty and staff as
well as alumni who have served or are
preparing to serve thank you for being
here with us today thank you all
[Applause]
during our ceremony you will hear from a
staff member and a current student and
in this year of celebrating women we
will also honor three women who have
supported and advocated for Yale
veterans we have a long history of
military leadership and advocacy at this
university that includes not only the
three extraordinary women we are going
to recognize today but also women like
Rear Admiral Grace Hopper for whom a
Yale was a residential college is named
and of course our own Linda Lorimer our
former secretary and vice president as
many of you know Linda is the daughter
of a Navy Rear Admiral and is a lifelong
advocate for our men and women in
service to our country
after many years of quiet remembrance of
our veterans
Linda initiated this event an official
university ceremony that publicly
recognizes the importance and the
contributions of veterans and what they
make for our lives at the University
Linda was also instrumental in the
return of the naval and Air Force ROTC
to Yale in 2012 and we can all see the
ROTC cadets and Midshipmen now they are
firmly established within the fabric of
our university culture they are welcome
and they are welcome and common sight on
campus as they move between the
classroom labs laboratories and
libraries as well as their
extracurricular activities the
residential colleges and of course their
military commitments so we're really
grateful to have her here with us today
our speakers presenters and honorees
represent commitment to honor and
country across multiple generations and
conflicts they represent all the
veterans here with us today and those
who care for them when today has passed
and we returned to our busy lives I hope
that all of us will continue to remember
the men and women of Yale who have
faithfully served and taken their oaths
to protect and to serve it is now my
pleasure to introduce president Peter
salivate who will share his thoughts
about our treasured veterans
[Applause]
Thank You Kim and thank you everyone for
being here it's really quite wonderful
to see so many people gathered here to
recognize Veterans Day to all of our
current and former servicemen and
servicewomen who are here today thank
you you have our deepest gratitude and
respect here with us today our faculty
staff students and alumni who are
veterans that legacy of service
continues today with the students who
are currently in the Reserve Officers
Training Corps on our campus we're proud
of the many men and women who have
served their country honorably over
three centuries we think of Nathan Hale
the out college class of 1773 perhaps
the most famous alumnus to serve in the
American Revolution at 21 he made
history when he said I only regret that
I have what one life to lose for my
country
others are perhaps less well known to us
Courtland Van Rensselaer Creed also made
history he was the first African
American to earn his medical degree from
Yale graduating in 1857 as soon as the
shots rang out over Fort Sumter
he wrote the governor of Connecticut
asking for a commission eager to defend
his country dr. Creed was rejected on
the basis of his skin color but when
black men were accepted into the Union
Army in 1863 he began writing again and
again until he received a commission as
Acting Surgeon of the 30th Connecticut
volunteers he served for the Wars
duration like dr. Creed another
remarkable Yale alumnus was determined
to serve Grace Hopper who received her
master's and PhD and
Maddox from Yale after the bombing of
Pearl Harbor she tried to enlist but was
rejected because of her age and small
size Harper persisted eventually
receiving a waiver to join the women's
US Naval Reserve she used her
mathematical abilities to develop
computers that aided in top-secret
calculations essential to the war effort
in 1946 the Navy declined her request
for a regular Commission due to her age
but she remained a naval reservist for
twenty years and then she was recalled
to active service for another nineteen
years
amazing grace hopper retired from the
Navy as Rear Admiral at the age of 79
the oldest serving officer in the US
Armed Forces hopper received many awards
and honorary degrees in her lifetime but
she would often say I have already
received the highest possible award the
privilege and responsibility of serving
in the United States Navy today and
every day we are inspired by the example
of our veterans and military service men
and women and we remember their
extraordinary sacrifices in service to
this country
Yale is proud to support our veterans
through the Yale veterans Network a
campus group for students faculty and
staff and the L Veterans Association an
alumni organization we want to support
all our veterans and so I'm asking for
your help employees can log in to
workday to self-identify as a veteran if
they wish to do so this is part of our
veterans count at Yale initiative it's
not required but it helps us give back
to those who have given so much to our
country
thank you for joining us here today
thank
you for helping us to honor our veterans
thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I now call upon the office of
the Yale University Police Department
who serve as our color guard please
stand as you are able as they offer the
presentation of the colors followed by
the playing of our National Anthem and
we're going to ask you to remain
standing for our invocation
[Music]
grand architect of the universe called
by many names in many languages by many
voices today we ask that your guiding
hands hold us and all sisters and
brothers in military service near we are
grateful for all who now serve all who
have served and for those who in the
words of Abraham Lincoln gave the last
full measure of devotion in service of
their country we are joined in humility
gratitude and our own measure of
devotion knowing that as we seek to
comprehend a complex world we are
sheltered by the vigilant service of
citizens to our Republic we ask special
regard for those who have served but who
have not yet been found and returned
home and for those who have returned but
who have yet to find themselves at home
we honor our military and ask that
whatever is required of them be informed
by your infinite wisdom the Luc's at
Veritas as they nobly and loyally seek
to create a peaceful and secure future
for us all
good afternoon as many of you know we
celebrate Veterans Day on November 11th
and remembrance of the armistice that
ended the first world war an armistice
that was signed on the 11th hour of the
11th day of the 11th month 101 years ago
today and it is on this great day that I
stand before you an Asian immigrant from
Korea the south side that came to the
United States at the age of 8 not
speaking any English and from the bottom
of my heart I'm grateful to this nation
a nation that is accepted somebody like
me a nation that represents hope and
unity a nation that has epitomized the
phrase the land of opportunity and a
nation that I had the pleasure of
serving in the United States Marine
Corps
like many my enlistment into the Marine
Corps came after a recruiter stopped by
on my high school the professionalism
the charisma but most importantly his
uniform caught the attention of my 18
year old self who didn't really know
what he wanted to do in life quite yet
and that night over dinner I told my mom
wouldn't happen at school all the while
hinting at the possibility that I was
thinking about joining the United States
military she asked me what branch of
service I was considering and when I
told her the Marine Corps her response
to me was do you think the Marines just
take anybody
so the very next day without telling her
I skipped school to go to the recruiting
office and sign all of the necessary
documents required for enlistment in
four years of honorable service and two
deployments later I can confidently say
the answer to my mother's question is
yes it turns out the Marines will take
just about anyone because they know how
to trade individuals to become Marines
first I'll break them down then download
them and they'll shape them into
painfully regretting their decision to
enlist with 5:00 a.m. PT runs weekly
inspections of your squad day for
cleanliness and just to keep the morale
high and to show them arrays the beauty
of the Santa Margarita Mountains of Camp
Pendleton they'll take you on hikes like
a lot of hikes then at the end of it all
you're presented with the Eagle Globe
and Anchor signifying your acceptance
into the ranks of the finest fighting
force in America
and in the Marine Corps I served as an
amphibious assault vehicle mechanic
entrusted with fixing a AVS which are
essentially just tank stock operate on
land and in water and after MOS school I
entered into the Fleet Marine Force and
learned something new about myself but
before I tell you this revelation you
have to understand that I signed up for
the only amphibious occupation in the
Marine Corps and this revelation of mine
would arrive just 10 minutes out in the
ocean during my first and fibia
operation as it turns out I suffer from
severe motion sickness out at sea not
something you want to find out as an
amphibious vehicle mechanic after you
had just became a mechanic so for all of
your future officers in the room please
hang out on a boat for a day or two
before decided to join the Navy or the
Marine Corps now I could stand up here
and tell you about my own personal
achievements or lack thereof
but there's
but what's what what's much more
important than that are the people that
I met while I was in service and on this
Veterans Day I want to highlight the
camaraderie and sacrifice that are
shared by those who served she was in
the Marine Corps and I met someone for
the first time in my life that was
willing to take the time to walk me
through something step by step until
they fully understood it selfless
individuals like corporal Jared Morris
but four months stayed behind a few
extra hours every night to teach me the
fundamentals of my job most people like
corporal justin Farnsworth who was
famous on our battalion for never
leaving the maintenance Bay and so the
job he was working on was finished and
these were the people that I aspired to
be like one day NCOs that were
dictionary definitions of what it meant
to be a Marine embodying honor courage
and commitment not only in the work that
they did but in ensuring that the lower
ranks through continued mentorship would
be prepared to fill their shoes upon
promotion and after about a year and a
half I was promoted to the rank of
Corporal and had become so proficient at
my job my callsign was echo for Yankee
whisky which stood for yellow wizard but
in all fairness my gunnery sergeant
gunnery sergeant Kiera was ghetto
chicken so I think I got off pretty easy
and it was through this promotion that I
realized the importance of putting in
the long hours and never giving up on
myself and discovered that if I put in
the work I can reach my full potential
it was the life lessons the experiences
and the successes in the Marine Corps
that gave me the confidence to go back
to school and as fate would have it in
my first math class back in Community
College I'm a petty officer second class
Jonathan Kong a Silver Star recipient
for his heroism in Afghanistan and a
corpsman who come to find out was on the
same ship that I was on deployment he
told me that he had just been accepted
to Dartmouth and that if I wanted he
would mentor me and when I said no
when I graciously accepted mr. trust me
you were going to get into Yale and it
turns out that he was right
see while here I wanted to give back not
only to my fellow veterans but to the
larger community and to reach that goal
I've been a mentor for other veterans
seeking higher education I started a
winter clothing drive to provide warm
clothes for the homeless in New Haven
and held a conference at the Omni Hotel
just last month shedding light on the
issue of wartime sexual violence against
women and on this 100 and first
anniversary of Armistice Day I'd like to
thank president Salome and secretary
golf crews for holding the ceremony and
to Dean Saudi for recommending me to
give these remarks and I'm honored to
continue the proud legacy of veterans
here at Yale the young men returning
from World War one and World War two and
young men and women of more recent
conflicts have used their time in Yale
to better serve their communities a
nation in the world happy Veterans Day
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon after such a poignant
playing of taps to member those who have
gone before we turn to honor those who
are very much with us it's a particular
delight to be here as we celebrate our
veterans and all who support them with a
special shout out for those are the
partners and spouses of our veterans and
those who are the children who are such
an important ingredient in every
military family I've had the honor of
co-chairing the group organizing the
year-long events in recognition of these
dual anniversaries of women at Yale the
fifty women at Yale 150 movement and
thus it was particularly gratifying that
our Yale Veterans Day committee decided
that they wanted this celebration to be
a part of the year-long event and wanted
to devote this year's awards to honoring
those women at Yale who have done so
much to advance the work of our veterans
and to advance veterans at Yale I like
to share a little bit about each of our
three honorees these remarkable women
and then we'll ask them to come forward
to so we can thank them collectively the
first is dr. Norma Thompson she's a
senior lecturer in the humanities the
associate director of the Whitney
humanities Center and the director of
the undergraduate studies program in the
humanities in Yale College she also has
been a key architect and constant
contributor to the warrior Scholar
Program as many of you know the warrior
scholar project was started right here
at Yale by students and graduates to
help enlisted veterans transition to
higher education the work started here
at Yale but now extends across the
country to 20 universities today one and
two week academic boot camps in the
human
and STEM fields are conducted at top
universities and these have helped to
repair literally thousands of veterans
to be successful as they begin or return
to college norma serves on the national
academic board of directors for the
warrior scholar project and designed the
original curriculum for the pilot
program here at yale in 2012 she's been
a lecturer in the yield program every
summer since and can be found also daily
eating with our veterans as they are are
getting acclimated to higher education
again so she provides the port way
beyond her outstanding contributions in
the classroom Patricia Way is a champion
for veterans a champion for veterans in
her role as associate director in Yale
College Admissions and for veterans
outreach she's recognized nationally for
her work in recruiting and also
supporting veterans with very high
potential to succeed in a rigorous
academic environment she's been
instrumental in increasing the number of
veterans enrolled in Yelle colleges Eli
Whitney students program as she and I
were visiting I was remembering when we
had 0 veterans in this program how
wonderful now that we are close to
having a score that program of course
supports students to come here who are
resuming their education after several
years of interruption
Patricia travels extensively to
community colleges to military bases and
works with service to school a national
nonprofit organization that helps
veterans apply to colleges and
universities but in addition to
recruiting veterans here
Patricia Mane's deep relationships a
real Network across this university both
administrators and faculty to create
literally a network that veterans can
walk into once they do matriculate here
as one of our colleagues said she is a
great collaborator as well as
contributor to veterans
our here at Yale the third woman we
recognize today is a 20-plus year staff
veteran of Yale and a veteran leader for
our University
Laurie Brasil is a director of finance
at the Yale School of Nursing she is an
Army veteran herself and the co-founder
and former co-chair of the Yale veterans
Network the Yale staff affinity group
and I must say it is so wonderful to
look out at this audience and see many
in that network who have really been
such contributors to Yale through the
service during your tenure here as well
as service to our country
Laurie is a third generation veteran and
also a second generation Yale staff
person she's a passionate advocate for
veterans her leadership has positioned
Laura as position Yale through her work
as an employer of choice for those
who've served our nation but she does so
many more to have the veterans if you
will mark be known by our greater
community she recently helped organize
the Yale football heroes day at the Yale
Bowl this yearly event brings together
veterans from the eastern blind
rehabilitation center with our own yell
veterans and ROTC cadets Midshipmen and
officers for an afternoon of football
camaraderie and patriotism or his
contributions to the Greater New Haven
community into Yale go even further
twice a year she organizes a group to
clean up the New Haven Veterans Memorial
a true labor of love I think and the
annual collection of items for the
Marines the Toys for Tots Drive is just
a way in which she with so many others
can signal to our larger community the
ongoing service that our veterans
provide these are just a few example of
Laurie's activities that embrace and
showcase that are in service these three
women through their hard work commitment
and dedication make the lives of our
veterans better and make Yale through
that a better place we and data Lee in
some
anyways are a stronger University
because of the growing complement of
veterans who are here as particular to
students and who are here in so many
important roles on our staff and faculty
Laurie Patricia and Norma please step
forwards we can thank you and present
you with certificates of appreciation
and some military coins small token of
our regard for how you have changed the
lives of veterans and this place for the
better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my sisters and brothers let us go forth
from the sacred space with grateful
hearts for the service and sacrifice of
our veterans and their families let us
never forget all they have done to
protect freedom and human rights as we
seek to grow closer to the abiding peace
our loving Creator intends for us may we
come to know a peace born from wisdom
and understanding a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy a peace
strengthened by courage and commitment
and may we be blessed this day and every
day by the shimmering light of our God
who creates sustains and embraces all
life amen
we're about to retire our colors and as
soon as we do that that will conclude
our Veterans Day ceremony many thanks to
the planning committee and our ceremony
participants especially Tom Duffy and
the Yale School of Music brass quintet a
quartet rather so I sure thank you so
much
so again we're gonna retire the colors
and please stay with us and then that
will conclude our services so thank you
for coming
[Music]